well I guess now that we don't get a saw
film every year and the Paranormal
Activity franchise is probably going to
start fizzling out soon we need another
one of these things to make a new one
every year the purge is now what we have
I'm so happy the purge too is the latest
sequel that no one wanted that we get to
watch in theaters yeah the first film
told the futuristic tale of one night
every year where murder and all crime is
legal crime is down in America in the
future because once a year murders cool
and rape and all that stuff the first
film is a home invasion thriller it took
place all in one house the second film
is out in the city with a whole bunch of
people so that should make it much more
thrilling and more intense correct I
don't usually like to compare other
people's opinions to support my own
because opinions are subjective film is
subjective I don't usually like to talk
about other sites that aggragate
people's opinions into a score but let's
talk about that for the first purge the
purge did not fare very well with people
on IMDB it didn't fare very well with
people on Ron tomatoes or the critics on
Rotten Tomatoes a majority of people
didn't like the purge that's all I'm
saying so why do we have a sequel
because it was made for next to nothing
and it made a lot of money on his
opening a weekend alone so we have
another one and we get to watch more of
it people are like well this one
actually takes place outside so it's
gonna be intense and more entertaining
right it's directed by the same person
and it's written by the same person why
would it be any different it's the same
movie it's just outside now see my
biggest problem with the first one was
that the only reason the movie even
existed besides the fact that it was an
interesting plot idea was because stupid
characters do stupid things and now
we're in this horrible situation like
usually a plot device in a movie is an
inanimate object or some thing that
allows the characters to progress along
in the movie in the first film the plot
device was actually people stupid
children who let people into their house
in the second one it's the exact same
way stupid dumb idiotic character
make really dumb decisions and suddenly
we're in a movie now early on in the
movie there is a killer coming into an
apartment and this stupid stupid girl in
a closet actually says we're back here
don't come in we have lots of guns now
what would you do in that situation hide
and don't say a word or blurt out
exactly where you are for the killer to
come in and find you now don't get me
wrong here I didn't miss the point of
this movie I understand the point of
this movie is that rich people or the
government try to control the population
in very bad ways sometimes you know it's
kind of a commentary on society the film
snowpiercer recently did that very well
but the reason that theme doesn't work
the reason doesn't hit home the reason
it's not powerful is because the film at
its core is really just a mindlessly
violent movie in which innocent
bystanders are killed in vicious ways
for two hours why would I want to watch
a movie like that it'd be one thing if
the movie was actually making a point
but the point the movie is trying to
make is for shattered by the fact that
the director keeps wanting to cut to
random people getting shot or stabbed it
doesn't have the impact it needs because
it becomes mindlessly and gratuitously
violent the best way that I can defend
the statement I just made is to describe
a scene in this movie the main
characters are walking by and see some
homeless people who are trying to shield
themselves from this night they're deep
underground they're barely visible at
all they've shoved themselves into this
corner you can't even see them they're
hiding all of a sudden this guy in this
car drives by he's got a flamethrower
he's just screaming and hollering at
everything as soon as the main
characters start to run away these
homeless people just flood into the
street for some reason they feel the
need to show themselves as soon as this
flamethrower guy comes out why so that a
whole bunch of faceless bodies can be
burned or shot or stabbed because the
director was like we need to kill some
people now let's just have these random
homeless people run into the middle of
the street despite the fact that they
should just hide they have no reason to
show themselves right now except for the
fact the script says that they need to
die the entire film is filled with
moments like that where characters just
do incredibly idiotic things that just
so happen to get them in the way of some
bullets or knives or fire because they
want
to show people being killed the theme of
the film is not effective at all because
the needless and gratuitous violence
overshadows it the film is filled with
idiotic and stupid characters there is
one saving grace to this movie and that
is Frank Grillo as the main character he
was great in the film
I thought he actually added a little bit
of humanity to it and you understood
where he was coming from there were no
real surprises with his character is
very obvious why he was doing what he
was doing it's just that he did a very
good job in the movie and gave the best
performance he was the only character
that wasn't a complete imbecile another
thing I really did not like about this
movie is that it's directed extremely
lazily a large majority of the scenes
are filled with close-ups like every
scene where a character is talking it's
almost always a close-up close-ups are
not used effectively in this movie also
there are many times in which you can
tell that he has a locked-down camera
very far away and that he's just zooming
in on people as they walk because that's
a very simple way to not have to do much
movement you can actually just stay in
the same position zoom in on two actors
and just kind of pan with them for a
while there's a lot of really lazy
camerawork like that overused use of
close-ups and whenever an actual shot
happens in the film where it actually
looks as if some effort was put into it
for instance a shot about twenty minutes
into the movie where two main characters
are running on an empty street and it's
panning down on the crane it was very
impressive because it was the first
actual shot in the movie that wasn't
just some guerilla style shaky cam
close-up a lot of the blood is CGI as
usual and it comes up as a gratuitously
violent needlessly disgusting movie and
it's themes are not realized because of
this I'm gonna give the purge Anarchy a
d-minus because Frank Grillo was good in
the film guys if you saw the first one
what was your opinion on it should we
have a sequel please don't let this
become the next saw or the next
paranormal activity
no more purchase please please please
please guys as always thank you so much
for watching and if you liked this you
can click right here and get stuck mine
eyes
if you guys have watched my previous
videos you know that I'm currently
running a promotion with audible.com for
a free audio book of your choice I've
downloaded Stephen King's books he's my
favorite author they have a very very
awesome selection of stuff there you can
listen to the books while you're on a
plane while your jog while you're in
your car wherever you are on your phone
on your tablet it's really convenient
for somebody who loves books and there's
a lot of really awesome people who are
narrating some of these books people
involved in film and in writing and I
really strongly suggest you guys
checking out audible.com slash Chris
that's my custom link in which you can
go and download a free audio book of
your choice audible.com got in contact
with me and wanted me to offer you guys
this promotion it's free if you would
like to check out an audio book of your
own go ahead and do that at audible.com
slash Chris thanks guys